yeah thank you everyone also from my
side and justice started off I'd like to
ask you three questions and just raise
your hand if the answer is yes so who of
you knows something about reinforcement
learning that's really good because I
don't really have a slide about what is
reinforcement learning kinda has seen
that the audience knows it already and
then two other questions maybe
concatenate into one who knows or play
Starcraft or dota 2 well more people
know about reinforcement learning than
bondo'd or Starcraft two teams which is
a good thing for this conference but in
order to start off this presentation I'd
like to go through the applications of
reinforcement learning that you might
see outside of the academic domain and
what better way to do that than to look
through non-technical publications and
different magazines and let's just start
off with the wired article from 2015
google's AI is now smart enough to play
Atari like the pros they don't call it
reinforcement learning but it's exactly
what it is moving on to 2017
deep mines AI became a super human chess
player in a few hours just for fun
well didn't think it was just for fun
but for some reason they decided to
build it like that and then quite
recently deep mines AI agents conquer
human pros at Starcraft 2 so January
24th 2019 and then moving on to April
April 19th opening eyes dota 2 team is
crushing humans online but players are
not giving up well let's see how did the
players do because two days later the
article came out which has has a
headline thankless the riot defeated
ninety nine point four percent of all
players in public matches so I guess the
point six percent did not give up in the
end but well you see these headlines and
you kind of notice they're all about
games where are the Google machine
translation applications of
reinforcement learning like Google
machine
translation uses NLP where's the image
search applications reinforcement
learning like image search uses
convolutional neural networks and
computer visions well I'll save you the
digging and I'll show you one of the
most impressive applications of
reinforcement learning so far and it
kind of looks like this yeah if I like
cheap jokes I'd say reinforcement
learning seems to have hit a wall here
and you seem to like this Rex as well
but welcome to my talk well here we will
talk about why don't you see actually
many real-world applications of
reinforcement learning
I'm Yuri too logical as the presenter
told me you can contact me on email and
LinkedIn and on github I'll upload the
slides by tonight at least I hope by
Monday for sure and you might see that I
work at BSF and you might think what
does BSF a chemical corporation even
have to do with the reinforcement
learning and the answer to that question
is really simple I'm not allowed to
reveal corporate secrets but if you
listen to the stock closely enough
you'll be able to make an educated guess
yourself and do keep in mind that the
talk isn't called why you do see many
applications of reinforcement learning
so multiple you can talk about this in
the Q&A or afterwards right having done
away with that introduction I'll just
jump right into the five problems that I
haven't identified in people in the
literature and fat as well I will just
walk one by one and discuss why is it
difficult for reinforcement learning to
jump across these this game pond and why
it doesn't seem to be a problem and in
these games so the biggest problem
perhaps and the one I would like to
start off with this sample inefficiency
example and efficiency means how much
data does an algorithm need in order to
be able to solve a task and in
reinforcement learning context data
doesn't come from data sets and we'll
talk about this problem later on
it comes from interaction with an
environment and this interaction of the
environment might be costly or might be
not so costly so in terms of simulated
environments
as games are it only requires
computational power but think for
example of an online shop that wants to
employ a reinforcement learning
technique in order to set pricing on the
things that it sells it has to make
suboptimal actions in order to explore
in order to generate this interaction
and has to consciously make actions that
it knows that aren't optimal and I don't
think any online shop would set prices
that it knows are not optimal just in
order to think it may be sometimes in
the future in five years I'll be able to
make an optimal action at some point so
if you don't have a good simulator
environment it's going to be hard to
adjust to this reinforcement learning
pipeline and just to go through the
algorithms that we showed make these
Atari games Starcraft DOTA let's see how
much interaction does it really require
in order to get to like appreciate the
scale so dqn is deep queue networks for
those who are more technical it's
Rainbow dqn as the paper crown came in
2017 is the state of the art application
of this algorithm and it needs to in
order to reach the hundred percent which
is the average human performance it
needs 18 million frames of gameplay at
60fps it's 83 hours you might think 83
hours doesn't sound too bad a real-time
play but consider how much a human needs
in order to play space invaders on an
average level I'd say a couple of
minutes and it needs to 83 hours moving
on to open AI 5 which is the dota 2
player or five players five agents this
is like really it really starts to get
scary here so they Hey they had 128
thousand CPUs 256 GPUs which isn't
really that much if all things
considered and they generated 900 years
of dota 2 experience per day so in
general
all in all they had 45,000 years of
experience which spent over ten months
because of course they had the resources
to see me simulate the aura that quickly
but if
you or I or anybody in this conference
would try to do it they probably just
take dota2 engine and there would be no
way to generate forty five thousand
years of experience because by then
people would probably don't wouldn't
care about reinforcement learning anyway
and then then this graph also from dota2
you see that there's more or less a
linear relationship between computing
power on the ax scale and the true scale
which is like a skill measurement on the
y scale except you see that the X scale
is logarithmic
oh I said logistic so it has to say
logarithmic so there's an exponential
increase in compute power and a linear
increase in true skill in the skill
level so it's not quite as efficient and
it's not quite as sustainable if you
don't have these massive resources and
that open AI to open AI has and opening
I actually admit it in their blog post
that the biggest increase it doesn't
come from the algorithms that they
develop the biggest increase comes from
the money that they pour it into Google
compute and then moving on to Starcraft
2 each dot represents an agent so one of
these dots actually then played against
a human the bad start so to say actually
it was a concatenation of different dots
but for our purposes we can think of one
dot as an agent and each agent was
trained up to 14 days with 16 GPUs and
in the span of those 14 days each agent
played 200 years of x star craft play so
600 agents 300 years 120 years of
real-time play in human terms and I
think I've driven my point pretty deep
I think you realized by now that sample
inefficiency is a big problem and the
only real solution to the sample and
efficiency is just stack more compute
power on top of it which isn't really
that sustainable especially not for the
huge powerhouses like and deepmind which
belongs to Google or open AI which just
has a lot of Manatee and unlike in
supervised learning why does the
reinforcement learning have this
specific problem because supervised
learning still needs a lot of data
but not quite as much we don't need to
train in our ResNet for 45,000 years we
just have it trained overnight if we
have a couple of GPUs the problem is
that we never see the true values we
never see the ground truths we generate
the data from experience and we estimate
the ground we estimate the actions that
we make but we never actually nobody
actually tells us this action is good
this action is bad we kind of make this
judgment ourselves based on the
experience and when we improve the
policy we have to make the judgments all
from the start and then there's this
vicious cycle it's not actually a cycle
it's more like a spiral because in the
end it does converge on the optimal
policy but it takes a very long time to
do so
and this is very different from
supervised learning and this is one of
the big reasons why you don't see
smaller companies employing
reinforcement learning and their
productive environments just one of the
five that I can't mention now you might
think transfer learning if it takes a
long time to train an algorithm why not
employ it transfer learning for those
who might not now what transfer learning
is is the idea is you take something
that was trained on one data set you
freeze most of it and then you retrain
the last parts in order to adapt it to
the new data set that you might have
well no such thing in reinforcement
learning right now you have to believe
me but I'll talk about why but for new
every new such task of reinforcement
learning every new environment every new
game every new whatever you have we have
to actually start from zero knowledge
zero priors so just as a recap faintree
transfer learning might look like this
for a computer vision task this is a
multi-layer convolutional neural network
you freeze the first layers and then you
retrain the top layers in order to adapt
you're already pre trained network on
image not for example to your specific
smaller data set in word embeddings in
NLP are also an example of transfer
learning because you don't need to train
the word embeddings you just download
them from google or whatever if you like
what worked evac it's Google if you like
globe a is from Stanford an LP and they
are just there you don't need to spend
your resources to to do it well in there
for sment learning like I said we don't
have data sets we have environments so
they might look like this this is like
an actual environment that you have to
train this is this isn't just the
visualization let break out but they
also have some more difficult ones like
this half cheetah it's called so you
have to make this type like cheetah run
because at first this is an example of a
well-trained environment and then you
have a very difficult one like this
humanoid and nobody supplies us the
ground truth since there are no data
sets
there's no direct notion transfer
learning there's some research about
transferring some prior knowledge right
now but it's very early and as it stands
right now even if your algorithm works
well on let's say space simulators you
wouldn't expect it to work at all on
breakout it might but that would be just
a matter of chance
next problem reward signal this is the
central idea of reinforcement learning
this is what it kind of defines
reinforcement learning
I'd even say reward is where our agent
tries to maximize over the whole run
from first step to the terminal step and
ideally the reward must capture our end
goal exactly so case in point master in
Atari games
the reward is the score that we achieve
with every step we improve our score by
five their world is five improve our
score by 50 their world is 50 and in the
end of goal in order to win the game we
must maximize the score so here the word
is the thing that we want to maximize
doesn't get better than that this is
exactly what we want to have let's think
of alpha zero here
the reward is simpler yet plus one for
winning the game - one for losing the
game and zero for draw and it works so a
solution to every reinforcement learning
problem considering the success of alpha
zero said plus one for a successful
completion of a task set minus 1 or zero
otherwise
and just solve any problem you might
have
if it were only that easy and observe
the emergence of a general artificial
intelligence is what I added this
morning well for any real reinforcement
learning tasks not gaming-related where
you don't have where you have many
states and many actions and not a little
action not many of those actions lead to
a terminal state you have to define some
reward function that makes intermediate
steps you can't just rely on plus one
for the terminal action and zero for
everything else we need reward shaping
and clear and creating this reward
function shaping this reward is very
difficult because we want the algorithm
to use this reward function to achieve
what we wanted to achieve and it only
can maximize the reward so we need to
make this reward somehow work in such a
fashion that it actually achieves what
we think it will achieve this is very
difficult so an example is this game the
word here is maximizing the high score
and the agent is the boat of course and
what you'll see it does it needs to get
to the end of the track but what you'll
see does it just collects these green
boosters because it increases this high
score that much that the agent doesn't
even really care about getting to the
end of the ego it's just gonna it just
gonna roll around roll around ad
infinitum and create and collect these
boosters so it maximizes this high score
but it doesn't really care about winning
and we wanted to care about winning so
this is an example of a failed shape
reward not gonna make it
struggle to the end so another example
of a failed shape reward is this half
cheetah
so expectation is this this is an
example of a well solved environment and
what it looks in reality is something
like this and from a mathematical point
of view this agent still collects a lot
of reward but does it really look like
what we wanted to look like I disagree
from every enforcement learners
perspective still works quite well
couple more and this is the one that's
most human-like but still not quite
right so there's a problem with now
seeming solution because we need a
reinforcement learning to maximize the
reinforcement learning agent to maximize
the reward but that doesn't mean that it
will do the thing that you want to do
eventually in the end by maximizing in
this reward and in some cases the reward
might be logically even connected to the
thing that you wanted to maximize like
an example of the boat but it still does
something completely different something
that you would have never expected when
you set it out and in the end it's a
matter of finding balance between a
sparse reward so that the agent actually
moves towards the end goal so sparse the
world would be just plus one for the for
successfully finishing a goal and given
these intermediate to shape rewards that
you that you've seen with this high
score in order for agent to actually
learn anything next and related thing is
exploration versus exploitation
trade-off fundamental problem do I
explore or do I exploit I need to make
sub optimal actions actions that I know
that are suboptimal in order to be able
to see if there are better actions out
there like in the example that I gave in
the very beginning with a shop I need to
make something that I know there's this
is gonna like cost me money in case of a
shop in order to know that in the end
the day it might bring me even more
money might not so this is the whole
idea of exploration and it's a trade-off
there is no clear there's no solution to
this trade-off you just have to take
take it as it is and turns out random
exploration is still kind of the best
way there is to explore there are all
these difficult algorithms that are even
hard to understand and then there's this
paper simple random search provides a
competitive approach to reinforcement
learning came out in 2018 kind of flew
under the radar of Reath
in community the algorithm looks like
this so the the juicy parts are here and
then the update step basically it's
simply a it's simply a matter of a
little augmented random search so random
search search is just to take a step in
one direction and then see if it was
good or bad then you take a step another
random direction see if it was getting
bad then updated your update your
preferences your policy and in such a
matter so no fancy evolution strategies
no fancy genetic algorithms just a
simple random search and this how it
works so these these are the
environments that I'll show you the half
cheetah Walker Sooners and Harper I
didn't see I didn't show RS and these
are the fancy algorithms PPO proximal
policy optimization this is the thing
that solved dota then TRP L trusted
region policy optimization actor to
critic and you see that the numbers here
except for the worker are actually
higher and this is a simple a very
simple algorithm that takes maybe 50
times less computational power than the
ones that are shown here to the right so
this is weird and this is I was very
surprised not to see a big uproar in the
reinforcement learning community and the
but this augmented random search beats
or at least is on par with the
state-of-the-art algorithm what this
means is that first of all we're not
very good at exploring better than
random we can't explore better than
random it also means that if a simple
algorithm beats or all our benchmarks
the benchmarks are pretty pretty poor
it's like having amnesty for computer
vision and not having anything higher
and then this we have 99.5% accuracy
right now and if that's all we had there
wouldn't be any improvement and this is
the probably the situation we have in
reinforcement learning right now so we
need new and more rigorous ways to tests
reinforcement learning algorithms and
then the problem probably the biggest
one is seed and hyper parameter
sensitivity it's an issue of
reinforcement learning that people just
started to tackle on just our
like catch one of it because before
people just submitted articles people
just submitted two algorithms to the
relevant publications just accepted
without giving much thought to the
sensitivity seat and hyper parameters
and we'll walk through why that is a big
problem so basically the way stuff works
right now is that you have your
algorithm you take three to five random
seeds so you have three to five runs of
your algorithm and you look at the best
one and you publish the results with the
best one in reinforcement learning
because it's it costs way too much it
takes way too long to run an algorithm
so it's understandable that people and
PhDs or Master students don't have the
money the universities don't supply the
money to actually run the algorithm
maybe a hundred times it's
understandable but it doesn't make it
less of a problem so this car is a
pretty significant problems that are the
ring for that the algorithms are very
sensitive so I hope you can see the
colors but maybe not the descriptions so
I'll just read off the descriptions for
you so here we have same algorithm same
code different activation functions and
you see the average return return is the
sum of reward over the whole run and you
can see that the blue the red and the
yellow are actually quite significantly
different here you also have different
activation functions and here the
biggest difference comes from a PPO so
proximal pulse optimization the
algorithm doesn't matter really that
much but there's the idea is that
there's a neural network in there and if
you have a different hyper parameter
settings a number of layers and number
of neurons in the layer you have a
vastly different performance so this red
and this blue might as well be two
different algorithms freely but they're
the same code the same implementation
the same hardware just two different
hyper parameters
same algorithm but different
implementations for example trust it
region policy optimization DDP G so TRP
oh and DDP G three different code bases
of the same algorithm same
implementation some of the smartest
people in the world did this code so
like PhD students or people from
research units of different companies
and you can see that these might as well
be different algorithms so something's
wrong it can't be that people who are
more or less on the same level read the
same papers have the same background
write the same try to implement the same
algorithm and then you have this this is
just this isn't just just a one-time
occurrence so this comes from in
different publications publication and
you'll see the sources for every
publication here down below if you want
to check it out for yourself after I
submit the slides to to github and
you'll see that there are these there
are these error bars and the error bars
are suspiciously close to zero which
means that I think it was 25 percentile
25% of the time the Elgar and just
doesn't work it just random and then
this comes from the Augmented random
search - so these are the environments
have cheetah
humanoid hopper and Walker swimmer
whatever and you see these are the
percentiles and for most of them some of
the percentiles pretty high ones for
example here's it's 20 20 % here
touches 0 so it means that 20% of your
time of the time your algorithm doesn't
do anything so imagine in computer
vision your algorithm works well 80% of
the time or it works at least somehow
20% of the time your image recognition
20% of the time it just doesn't manage
to even pick up on random noise like it
doesn't manage to go higher than random
noise and I'm pretty sure that if you
ran your computer vision image
recognition algorithm hundred times on
the same data set with the same code
you'd have the same result 100% of that
may be a matter of a margin of error of
three five percent not like it works or
it doesn't and then alpha zero the
algorithm that everybody likes and knows
and it's a pretty simple one takes maybe
like hundred 50 lines of codes to
implement for me and for people who know
what they're doing maybe even less so
you see there are no error bars so two
reasons either the errors are so small
that they don't even fit on the on the
graph or there are no error bars because
they only reported one run of the
algorithm and it's the second reason and
they were called out on it on the
conference and they said yeah internally
we tried a lot but we only reported one
run I don't know if you tried a lot and
why they only report one run so
basically all these impressive results
that we see about beating go play best
go player and best chess and shogi
algorithms because algorithms are way
better than best players by now in chess
and she okay this is just a result of
one single run so we don't know if they
were to try it again if it would work if
it would not perhaps it wouldn't given
the given the sensitivity of the other
algorithms to reinforce to seed and
hyper parameter and alterations so deep
reinforcement results are actually not
that reproducible due to intrinsic and
extrinsic factors of course they are
relatively reproducible and so you see
algorithms that seem to work really well
they seem to be really impressive when
they work but some of the time and a lot
of the time they actually don't and this
is also a very thing that's very
intrinsic to reinforcement learning that
you don't see in supervised learning and
it comes from the same problem of data
sets versus environments of round
through vs. interaction with environment
so your resonate for example would work
the same
you'd expect this work in the same way
if it's implemented in the same way on
the same data set but in the
environments is a whole different game
because you have your interaction that's
dependent on your for example neural
network if you're up there if you have
parallel tries your policy by neural
network so your neural network and all
the randomness that happens in neural
network directly affects the interaction
and that interaction is what contributes
to your data the reward and the new
state and the transition that you have
so your random is that influences your
neural network directly influences your
data that you generate live on the go
and the data that you generated live
then influences the neural network
because you update it with a new return
and then so on so on so on so the
smaller our alterations not only
influenced your neural network but also
the data generation with Jewish data
generation then influences the neural
network and then it goes like that in a
vicious cycle and that's why you see
this convergence divergence er
you see convergence and the algorithm
but if you look through different
implementations of the algorithm or
different hyper parameters or different
seeds even with the same hyper air
parameters you see a huge divergence
because of this amplification of error
amplification of randomness that goes
for in this cycle so the problem here is
that even if you if you wanna employ and
reinforcement learning algorithm in
production you look through papers you
see ok this algorithm works the best
then you implement it
or you take the reference implementation
and set a random seed or set it have a
parameter setting and it might work like
a completely different algorithm in the
end so there you can't be sure that if
you take the best algorithm the best
perform alder and you can't be sure that
it's going to be performing quite that
well on your data set or your data set
was even a wrong word to use on your
task on your environment that you have
that you have developed for the
reinforcement learning agent to tackle
on this is a big problem
so you might be thinking by now this guy
seems to criticize a lot but doesn't
offer any solutions and the hard and sad
truth is that I don't have any solutions
and my defense I don't think anybody
right now has any solutions to these
problems I'm just here to like draw
attention to the problems and draw
attention to the problems that we should
be tackling on if you want to have
reinforcement learning work well enough
in order to for it to be stable enough
to make this jump over from games to
actual environments where women can make
maybe even money with it so the biggest
of than--than seems to actually scale up
with a hardware increase this is
something to consider we need somewhere
how somehow if we if we are to keep if
we can keep up with the exponential rise
of hardware it's cool but we probably
aren't especially with the more law in
every year and we need something that
would make reinforcement learning need
less experience it would be more sample
efficient then we can use reinforcement
learning as a suggestion as a science
Janine Fantine and step on top of a
supervised learning approach for example
alpha zero did just that
first they took another alpha 0 alpha
star first they took the games that pro
gamers played in starcraft 2 they
trained there they pre trained their
agents on those games so there you had
actually ground truth at this situation
this move is the best train your agent
to do this move at this situation and
then on top of that they did a
reinforcement learning agent where the
agent where the agents played against
themselves and this is how they achieved
this subhuman expla Love play super
human is what I meant
so reinforcement learning not in and of
itself but on top of a supervised
learning approach something to consider
there's a lot of potential in learning
for some learning transfer learning
because right as of right now it just is
not existent there are some
papers who try to do this but it doesn't
get any further than a couple of papers
and in those papers it doesn't get any
far so if we can do that then for
example me I could just download a
pre-trained policy and retrain the
policy on a new task and be happy with
it and do some research or thinking or
whatever and if a lot of people in the
world do that then the field will
advanced much much much quicker so we
need something like an image net model
for our image net data set rather for
reinforcement learning because image net
is what kind of jumpstart the computer
vision revolution in 2012 people just
could download pre train networks tinker
a little with it apply the new data set
and it just worked perfectly and then
lastly we need more in general
comprehensive environments environments
are kind of like benchmarks so imagenet
because right now we have something like
a menace for reinforcement learning
these environments are pretty easy as we
seen these environments are really easy
we have as really simple random search
algorithm that solves the environment in
a matter of hours so in order to
differentiate these simple algorithms
from the difficult ones from the
sophisticated ones we need something of
a higher capacity of a higher
differentiating capacity so to say which
is like imagenet for example for
computer vision so no solution a lot of
problems but no solutions but if or
rather when these solutions are going to
be presented and these problems are not
maybe not going to be solved but at
least going to be tackled on a little
maybe I'll have a reinforcement learning
agent that doesn't hit into a wall so
remember I said that that was one of the
most impressive applications of
reinforcement learning so then for the
most impressive application looks like
this
and hopefully this figurative wall won't
be a problem anymore not only for this
humanoid model but for the bigger
community of reinforcement learning
agents researchers engineers and
hopefully you'll see reinforcement
learning being employed too for a
greater good in the general world all
over with that I end thank you thank you
very much yes
let's start with the questions and thank
you for that I can reham actually
anything you mentioned it's it's quite
the truth from when I used to get in
touch with reinforcement learning now
the question is and what I was missing
is the robotics part not like for human
need robotics but smaller tasks and
whatever you know can you tell us how's
how's the current state with robotics I
had the impression they are successful
appliances for that with reinforcement
learning oh and how far does get for now
yeah yeah so what I didn't mention
because I thought I wouldn't have time
but maybe I would have now I wouldn't
have time is muddle free versus
model-based approaches so model free is
when you interact with the black box and
model basis when you interact with the
environment that you have a model of and
in robotics you'd have a model because
it's just physics is the model of the
interaction and this works much better
but it's also works in simulation like
all the approaches that I know our first
simulate the environment with the
physics that you have and then maybe
transfer it to a real world like robot
arm that you have and sometimes that
works but like every single actual
application like cuca robots or Boston
Dynamics they don't do reinforcement
learning they do basic physical physics
based applications and I really try to
find a robotics application that's more
than just a toy and I just couldn't
[Music]
I was curious about the Augmented random
search algorithm do you know in the
paper did and it seems like they is kind
of like the example you gave before you
kind of they picked one example of the
algorithm running and compared it
against the other kind of pre trained
algorithms you didn't see like the
convergence graph do you think that that
if they were to like if you were to
actually compare it more rigorously do
you really think Eris would would beat
out some of these more trained
algorithms or is there just not enough
information about that right now so what
they did is what I showed is not the
convergence graph but the performance
over like hundred random seats to see
the different the vastly different
performances but the the thing is that
in terms of the benchmark is the reward
that you collect over a certain amount
of steps so you let and in a hundred you
let the environment do hundred steps you
and do this environment with the random
search or you do this environment within
you know PPO approximate policy
optimization and you see how many how
much reward was collected with one or
algorithm how much reward was collected
with different algorithm and in the end
it was super surprising to me that it
was not quite clear but it was like not
day and night they were really really
close to each other so sometimes the
actual random search one sometimes the
more sophisticated algorithms won but it
wasn't like I would expect the random
search war to work in different domains
just for my own comprehension am I to
understand that the that one of the main
problems with RL is is path dependency
is what do you mean by that
well you were talking about how at one
point and I only caught half of it
because I was taking notes how the
action of the gym mmm then influences
yeah the environment in this in this
sense yeah the big problem is that yeah
the path depends is because if you add
the
beginning you make some action it
actually influences the data collection
process through the whole run until the
terminal point so in this sense it's
very much a dependency problem and these
random effects influence the first step
and then interest rolls on top of that
you mention about dynamic pricing
problem at the beginning of your talk I
personally would be interested in your
view on dynamic programming applications
for these problems well for that yes
thank you for dynamic programming
dynamic programming is a big part of
reinforcement learning but for that you
have to what I decide model based versus
model 3 for dynamic programming you have
to have a transition function you have
to know the probability of transition
into a new state and the probability of
receiving a reward with that transition
and it's really hard to do that it's
really it's easy in the physics-based
environment because you have for example
just the physics equations that handle
that for you but in terms of a dynamic
pricing approach how do I predict if I
set a price to P how to predict the
expected reward of that action and how
do I predict the state that I'm gonna be
in after that action I'm not really sure
how how do you even go about creating
this kind of environment an environment
is basically what you need for
reinforcement learning algorithm to even
work yeah I was absolutely a
[Music]
thank you what type of what areas of
research or heuristic discovery
algorithms are you personally interested
in or encouraged by I like model-based
approaches more right now because they
are tackling this sample and efficiency
problem because like I repeat myself but
for example alpha zero is a model-based
approach because it has the game of
chess in itself it knows if I do this
step it knows where I'll end up and
where what my board will look like but
it still if you have a model it still
doesn't mean that you know how to play
well or optimally because we all know
how chess works but we don't know how to
win at chess at least I don't and this I
think is very is very promising field
because it lets you plan ahead and it
means that you don't need to have just
as much experience as if you would have
with a random box or in necessarily not
random box black box kind of environment
so I think this is this is something
that we should as a community of people
who are interested in reinforcement
learning tack along and I think this is
quite promising I have a question
recently we saw some postman of
hide-n-seek using reinforcement learning
yeah and these agents learned strategies
the question is how do you see
applications in let's call it strategy
search maybe in game theory applications
using vim for learning and whether you
know something already on that yeah well
strategy is and the sons just look up
for every state word word what action do
you take right and this is exactly what
reinforcement learning is supposed to
make because it state as it gives you
like a probability or like a
recommendation of steps that you need to
take of all the possible actions and in
this sense it is exactly this but on a
third and I don't know about this
seeking stategy so I'm not not really
able to answer this question all right
so we're writing time for changing rooms
if you want so let's think judy again
please
[Applause]